SEND THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IT
IS TUESDAY JUNE TWELFTH WE DO
NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM BUT WE
HAVE ENOUGH.
START AS A SUB COMMITTEE SO WE
WILL DO THAT.
SENATOR WELCOME.
YOU ARE
HERE.
SO WE WILL TAKE YOU UP NOW AND
THAT IS OUR ITEM FOR. WHICH IS
SJR SIXTEEN.
JOIN THE AUTHORED BY SENATORS
WILK AND HUESO.
SIR THANK MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
NOT BEHALF OF MYSELF AND CENTER
BEN HUESO I'M PRESENTING AS J.
R. SIXTEEN CALLING ON THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO EXTEND THE
TEMPORARY PROTECTED STATUS FOR
RESIDENTS FROM THE COUNTRIES OF
EL SALVADOR. HAITI HONDURAS
NICARAGUA IN THE SUDAN.
LAST DECEMBER I MET WITH A GROUP
OF SALVADORANS FROM MY DISTRICT
REGARDING AT THAT TIME THE
PENDING EXPIRATION OF THE OF THE
TPS PROGRAM. AND THEIR STORIES
REALLY MOVE ME I HAD ONE
CONSTITUENT. HER FAMILY FLED
DURING THE CIVIL WAR SHE SHE
LEFT AL SALVADOR AYE IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR AT THE AGE OF EIGHT.
I CAME HERE.
TO THIS COUNTRY.
.
QUALIFY FOR THE TPS PROGRAM HER
AND HER HUSBAND.
THEY MARRIED IN NINETEEN NINETY
SIX.
BOTTA BOUGHT A HOME TOGETHER NO
FOUR IN THAT NOW THEY HAVE TWO
ADULT CHILDREN THEIR ELDEST
DAUGHTERS TWENTY SIX HAS A
CAREER THEIR SON IS STILL IN
COLLEGE AT THE AGE OF. TWENTY
AND ONE THING SHE DID SHE BEAMED
WITH PRIDE TELL ME HOW THEY CAME
HERE ON THEIR OWN NEVER ACCEPT
ANYTHING FROM THE GOVERNMENT.
WANTED TO DO IT ON THEIR OWN AS.
MOST AMERICANS DO IN YOU KNOW
LIKE SO MANY TPS HOLDERS THEY
WERE DEVASTATED.
WHEN THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
YOU KNOW CANCELED.
A TPS FOR SALVADORANS AND THEIR
FRIEND ABOUT THE PROSPECT OF
BEING SEPARATED FROM THEIR ADULT
CHILDREN.
AS WELL AS GOING BACK TO COUNTRY
THAT THEY DON'T KNOW WOULD NOPE
NO WHERE TO LIVE NO PROSPECTS
FOR EMPLOYMENT IN MOST OF ALL
THE FEAR THE VIOLENCE GANGS AND
POLITICAL UNREST THAT STILL.
OCCURS THERE.
AND AS YOU ALL KNOW THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IT'S ALSO
TERMINATED THE TPS PROGRAM FOR
HAITI NICARAGUA AND SUDAN. AND
LAST MONTH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ANNOUNCED THE END
OF THE TPS PROGRAM FOR CURRENT
HONDURAS WHICH IS THE SECOND
LARGEST GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT
BENEFIT FROM THIS OP PROTECTED
STATUS.
TBS HOLDERS HAVE ALREADY
FULFILLED MANY THEIR CORE
REQUIREMENTS FOR LAWFUL
PERMANENT RESIDENTS EVERYDAY
THEY DEMONSTRATE THAT THEY
BECOME FULL MEMBERS OF SOCIETY
THROUGH EMPLOYMENT.
HOMEOWNERSHIP IN THE RAISING OF
THEIR CHILDREN AS MY PRIOR STORY
OF MY CONSTITUENT ILLUSTRATES.
TOGETHER AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SHOULD EXTEND TPS FOR
ALL MEMBERS FROM ALL THESE
COUNTRIES WHILE ALSO WORKING
TOWARD A PERMANENT SOLUTION FOR
RESIDENCIES. FOR THESE RESIDENTS
THIS BIPARTISAN RESOLUTION IS
COMMITTED TO OUR SHARED VALUES
OF JUSTICE AND FAIRNESS AND
PROTECTING OUR TPS.
HOLDERS
OUT OF WHO WANTED LIVE IN
AMERICA AND EMBRACE OUR IDEALS
SO WITH THAT I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
ANYONE WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS RESOLUTION.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
ADDRESS.
SENATOR DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE A MEMBER OF
THE ASSEMBLY WHO CAME FROM ITS
ON THE VOTE.
AT THE WITH HER GRANDMOTHER AND
IT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT PROGRAM
I.
OUR COMMUNITIES RESOLVE OTHER
AUTUMN GOOD US ARE DEVASTATED BY
THE FACT THAT.
THIS ADMINISTRATION CHOSE TO END
THE PROGRAM SO THANK YOU AND
WHEN THE TIME IS CORRECT WE HAVE
A QUORUM. I WOULD BE HONORED TO
MOVE IT.
THANK YOU AND CENTER I'D MET
ALSO APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS FOR EFFECTS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TRAVEL TELL
SALVADORAN.
SEE WHAT THE SENATE GOVERNMENT
IS TRYING TO DO TO TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT DROVE
FOLKS OUT.
THIS COUNTRY ALSO HAS PLAYED A
ROLE AND THE INSTABILITY IN THAT
REGION AS WELL AND SO FOR US TO
ABANDON THE PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE.
AYE DO HAVE A NUMBER OF EL
SALVADORANS.
IN IN MY DISTRICT IN THE AREA
THAT I'M.
THURMOND PRETTY FAMILIAR SO I
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
SORT OF THING IS VERY
APPROPRIATE STATEMENT FOR GREAT
CALIFORNIA TO MAKE OUTGOING
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS YOU MAKE.
I JUST AS IF YOU LIKE. A
DISASTER AND I ABOUT WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR YOUR OFFER TO MOVE IT.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
WE HAVE TWO MORE BILLS TO HILL
TO HEAR CENTERS HILL AND BELL.
UPSET ABOUT YOUR.
YOU'RE HIDING IN THE CORNER
YOU'RE NOT ONE WHO TYPICALLY
HIDES SO WE'LL MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO S. B. TEN FIFTY THREE.
ALRIGHT GREATS.
MORNING WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR.
THIS FINE DAY.
.
I PRESENTING.
SP.
TEN FIFTY THREE IF I COULD.
AW THIS BILL IS A CLARIFICATION
OF EXISTING LAW.
THAT PROTECTS VICTIMS OF
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ABUSE.
IT'S EQUIVOCATION NOT REALLY A
CHANGE IN THE LAW.
NOW THE GOVERNMENT TOWARDS A
CLAIMS ACT REQUIRES A CLAIMS
RELATED TO DEATH FOR INJURY.
MUST BE PRESENTED NO LATER THAN
SIX
MONTHS.
AFTER THE INCIDENT OCCURRED.
SANSA CASES INVOLVING CHILD
ABUSE ARE DISTINCT IN NATURE.
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED SP SIX FORTY.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINE.
EXEMPTING CASES OF CHILD SEXUAL
ABUSE FROM THE TORT CLAIMS
PROCESS.
MORE TIME IS ALLOWED BECAUSE OF
THE TRAUMA LATE DISCOVERY OF
ABUSE BY A PARENT OR GUARDIAN.
OR THE CHILDREN NOT TELLING
ANYONE.
EXPERTS ESTIMATE THAT ONE OF
FOUR GIRLS AND ONE SIX BOYS.
WILL BE SEXUALLY ABUSED BEFORE
THEIR EIGHTEENTH BIRTHDAY.
AUTUMN LESSON ONE IN TEN
ACTUALLY TO TELL ABOUT IT.
SO THE LEGISLATURE ACKNOWLEDGED
THIS.
AND ESTABLISH S. B. SIX FORTY.
THAT THAT.
IT WAS UNREASONABLE TO EXPECT
THE CLAIM WILL ALWAYS BE FILED
SIX MONTHS.
AFTER THE ACTUAL ABUSE OCCURS
WITH THE CHILD UNITS
YOU THINK ABOUT IT IT'S.
KIND OF OFF LOGICAL.
LEGISLATIVE COMPS QUICKLY
VERSION.
.
AND THAT'S WHY THE BILL WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW.
YET THERE'S BEEN MANY CASES
HANDLED IN WAYS THAT WERE NOT IN
WITHIN THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
AN SP.
TEN FIFTY THREE CLARIFIES THAT
VICTIMS.
WHO COULD SPEAK UP SOONER WILL
DO SO LATER?
THE BILL IS AIMED AT PROTECTING
THE CIVIL LEGAL RIGHTS.
OF THOSE INJURED THROUGH CHILD
SECTION CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ABUSE
ALLOWING THEM.
TO SEEK COMPENSATION FOR PUBLIC
OR PRIVATE AND HE'S INVOLVED. WE
HAVE SOME WITNESSES EITHER TURN
THEM OVER TO THE WITNESSES
MISTER CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ATTENTION THIS MONKEY
CENTER TALK FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
HELLO GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
CASSANDRA IDEAS I AM A CURRENT
JUNIOR AT CAL LOLLIPOP CAL POLY
POMONA.
MY LIFE WAS CHANGED FOREVER WHEN
I WAS A YOUNGER ON THE THIRD
GRADE MAYFAIR TEACHER WAS MISTER
BURNS. MISTER BERMAN ME FEEL
SPECIAL YOU MAY BELIEVE I WAS
HIS FAVORITE STUDENT AND HE EVEN
GIVE ME A NICKNAME LUCKY.
HE WAS A VERY POPULAR TEACHER
AND EVEN GAIN THE TRUST OF MY
FAMILY. DIGGING MY CHOSE TO THE
POINT WHERE I AM BACK INTO
SEVERAL PRETTY PARTY'S.
AS A THIRD GRADER IN THE TWO
THOUSAND FIVE THROUGH TWO
THOUSAND SIX SCHOOL YEAR I
COULDN'T HAVE KNOWN AS BEING
GROOMED AND APPEARS.
BUT IT WASN'T JUST ME MISTER
BARRETT ABUSE OVER A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY. ARE CHILDREN.
ITS HARD TO DESCRIBE BUT I WILL
BE BRIEF.
MR BURR PLAYED A GAME OF THE
THIRD GRADERS HE TOOK US INTO A
BOOK HE TOOK US BOTH IN
INDIVIDUALLY AND AS GROUPS TO
THEIR CLASSROOM.
HE WOULD COVER THE WINDOWS AND
CLOSE THE DOORS.
HE WOULD THEN PLAY A TASTING
GAME WHERE HE WOULD PUT SUGAR ON
COOKIES AND HE WOULD HAVE A SEAT
THE COOKIES ARE HE PHOTOGRAPHED
US.
THE SUGAR WAS ACTUALLY MIX WITH
MISTER BYRD STING SEAMAN.
HE ALSO SPOON FED SEMEN TO
CHILDREN AS WELL WHILE TAKING
PICTURES AND OTHER OCCASIONS
MISTER BERT WOULD HAVE CHILDREN
TIE HIM UP IN A CHAIR TO
SIMULATE EROTIC BONDAGE.
MR BURR WAS NOT A RESIDENTIAL
FEBRUARY TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
THAT SIX YEARS AFTER I LEFT HIS
CLASS.
IT WAS THEN THAT IT WAS
DISCOVERED THAT THIS TAKE TASTE
TESTING GAME. HAD AN EVIL AND
THE PURPOSE.
THERE IS NO WAY WE COULD HAVE
MANY SIX MONTH FILING DEADLINE
FROM THE DATE OF THE LAST MONTH
STATION AS WE DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
WE WERE BEING ABUSED UNTIL SIX
YEARS LATER.
AFTER HIS ARREST BECAME PUBLIC I
FELT SO DISGUSTED BETRAYED INTO
SIVA MISTER BURNS AND NEED A
MONTH ALIMENTARY.
I LOST ANY SENSE OF TRUST IN
ADULTS AND HAD A SEVERE LOSS OF
APPETITE I HAD PROBLEMS BEING
ALONE AND. BEING ABLE TO SLEEP.
I WAS LATER DIAGNOSED WITH PTSD
THIS IS VERY COMMON WITH THE
OTHER CHILDREN AS WELL.
WE LATER LEARNED THAT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT FAILED TO TAKE ACTION
ON MULTIPLE COMPLAINTS AGAINST
MISTER BURN.
YEARS EARLIER INCLUDING
COMPLAINS THAT HE WAS SEEN*
AGAINST ON BEHIND HIS DOES AND
REPORTS OF HIM HAVING HIS HANDS
DOWN HIS PANTS I RECESS.
THIS GROSS ABUSE COULD HAVE BEEN
LONG PREVENTION.
OUR KIDS IS IMPORTANT NOT TO
GIVE KIDS LIKE ME TOOLS TO SEEK
THERAPY BUT ALSO TO MAKE A
SOCIAL CHANGE.
BECAUSEOF OUR CASE A ZERO
TOLERANCE POLICY FOR EMPLOYEE
MISCONDUCT WAS ENFORCE ANY
REVEAL THE EMPLOYEE FILES GOING
BACK DECADES WAS ORDERED IN AN
EFFORT TO RID THE DISTRICT OF
POTENTIAL PROBLEM EMPLOYEES.
THE LAW NEEDS TO PROTECT KIDS
LIKE ME S. B. TEN FIFTY THREE
DOES THAT BY CONFIRMING THE
EXISTING LAW FEASIBLE A.
THANK YOU BEST WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS HOLLY BOYER.
RECOGNIZING THE UNIQUE NATURE OF
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ABUSE CASES THE
LEGISLATURE IN TWO THOUSAND TWO
AMENDED CODE OF CIVIL PROCEDURE
THREE FORTY POINT ONE. TO EXTEND
THE PERIOD WITHIN WHICH A VICTIM
OF CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ABUSE MUST
FILE INACTION.
WELL THE EXTENDED PROTECTIONS OF
SECTION THREE FORTY POINT ONE.
WERE INTENDED TO EXTEND TO ALL
VICTIMS WHETHER THEIR INJURIES
AROSE FROM THE NEGLIGENCE OF
PUBLIC OR PRIVATE ENTITIES.
THE LAW WAS NOT SO APPLY.
INTO THOUSAND SEVEN THE SUPREME
COURT DECIDED SHIRK VERSUS VISTA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT FINDING
THAT THERE WAS NOTHING IN THE
GOVERNMENT CODE. OR ELSEWHERE
RELIEVING A VICTIM OF SEXUAL
ABUSE FROM HAVING TO COMPLY WITH
THE GOVERNMENT CLAIMS ACT.
CORD HIGHLIGHTED THAT IF THE
LEGISLATURE INTENDED FOR ALL
VICTIMS TO BE TREATED THE SAME.
AND AFFORDED THE EXTENDED
PROTECTIONS OF THREE FORTY POINT
ONE IT COULD HAVE SAID SO AND IT
DIDN'T. THE LEGISLATURE
RESPONDED.
WITHIN MONTHS OF THE SHARK
DECISION AND WITH FULL
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
SENATE BILL SIX FORTY PASSED IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
CREATING SUBDIVISION M. TO
SECTION NINE ALL FIVE OF THE
GOVERNMENT CODE.
LIKELY EXEMPTING VICTIMS OF
CHILD SEXUAL ABUSE FROM HAVING
TO FILE TORT CLAIMS.
DESPITE THE LEGISLATURE'S DIRECT
ACTION IN RESPONSE TO SHIRK.
SEVERAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
NOW ATTEMPTED TO CIRCUMVENT
SUBDIVISION THEM BY AN ACTING
THEIR OWN LOCAL REGULATION.
IMPOSING A CLAIM FILING
REQUIREMENT ON THESE VICTIMS.
THESE LOCAL PUBLIC ENTITIES ARE
RELYING ON A FLAWED
INTERPRETATION OF GOVERNMENT
CODE SECTION NINE THIRTY FIVE TO
JUSTIFY THIS ABSOLUTE DISREGARD
FOR THE INTENTION OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
SENATE BILL TEN FIFTY THREE
CODIFIES AND CLARIFIES EXISTING
LAW THAT PROTECTS VICTIMS OF
SEXUAL ABUSE. FROM THE ONEROUS
GOVERNMENT CLAIM PRESENTATION
REQUIREMENTS.
THINKING.
THANK YOU GOTTA TAKE A PAUSE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM PLEASE STONE
HERE CUNNINGHAM. CHAU. CHIU
HOLDEN KALRA KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
THERE
REYES.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
YOU HAVE A CORE SO THERE'S A
MOTION AND A SECOND ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS
THIS COMMITTEE.
KIND OF VALENTINE FROM
CALIFORNIA PROTECTIVE PARENTS
ASSOCIATION IN FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING NANCY PERINEUM WE
HAVE THE CONSUMER TRAYS OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE THE SPONSOR OF
THE BILL THINKING.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE THEIR OPPOSITION
.
GOOD MORNING MR WHERE MEMBERS
FAVORING Y. JUST ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
JOINT PARROT THE RADIUS. IN VERY
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION OF THE
SPELL.
IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES AND
EIGHTIES PUBLIC AGENCIES WERE
FACED WITH EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE
PRIVATE SECTOR INSURANCE COSTS
THAT PROVIDED VERY LITTLE
COVERAGE. AND MANY INSURANCE
COMPANIES WERE UNWILLING OR VERY
RELUCTANT TO PROVIDE INSURANCE
PRODUCTS TO PUBLIC AGENCIES.
THE PUBLIC ENTITY RISK PULLING
JP IS WHERE ESTABLISH AND AS A
RESULT MANY PUBLIC AND EIGHTY IS
INCLUDING MORE THAN A THOUSAND
SCHOOL. AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS USE THIS MODEL TO
EFFECTIVELY SELF INSURE FOR
LIABILITY AND OTHER INSURANCE.
OBLIGATIONS AND NONPROFIT RISK
POOLS.
WHERE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL WHICH ATTEMPTS TO
OVERTURN THE RECENT APPELLATE
COURT HOLDING AND BIGELOW FLAT
GROVELING UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT VERSES THE SUPERIOR
COURT? WHERE THE COURT REASONED
THAT GOVERNMENT TOWARD?
CLAIMS ACT REQUIREMENT OF PRE
LAWSUIT NOTICE AFFORDS A PUBLIC
ENTITY AND OPPORTUNITY TO
PROMPTLY REMEDY ACCLAIM BEFORE
INCURRING THE COSTLY EXPENSIVE
GOING TO ACQUIRE. AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DO A TIMELY INVESTIGATION
WERE TANGIBLE EVIDENCE IS STILL
AVAILABLE AND MEMORIES ARE FRESH
AND ALLOWS THE PUBLIC AND EIGHTY
TO PROPERLY BUDGET THE EXPENSE.
THIS COMMITTEE TYPICALLY DOES
NOT ENCOURAGE LOGICALLY XIN
WHERE THERE IS ONGOING
LITIGATION AND THIS CASE HAS
BEEN APPEALED TO THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT.
CATCH UP OF FULLY ACKNOWLEDGES
AND RESPECTS THE RIGHTS OF
VICTIMS OF CHILDHOOD SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
STORY WE JUST HEARD IS TRULY
HEARTBREAKING AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE INSTANCES.
ARE LIMITED AND NEVER HAPPEN IN
THE FUTURE. BUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF LEGITIMATE CLAIMS BEING
PRESENTED AND ADDRESSED.
IT'S WHAT WE'RE HOPING TO DO
WITH THESE CLAIMS PROCEDURES.
TO DENY CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
ENTITIES THE RIGHT TO PROMPTLY
RECEIVE PRE LAWSUIT NOTICE AND
INVESTIGATE INITIATE
INVESTIGATIONS AND SETTLEMENT
NEGOTIATIONS EARLY. HURTS NOT
ONLY THE PARTIES INVOLVED BUT
THE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYER WHO
ULTIMATELY BEARS THE COST OF
THESE LAWSUITS AND IT ALSO HURTS
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO RELY ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT SERVICES THAT
ARE RESTRICTED AS A RESULT.
I REALIZE THAT IT PRESENTED A
FISCAL CONCERN BUT BECAUSE THAT
THAT WAS NOT TIGHT FISCAL I HAVE
THE OBLIGATION TO PRESENT THOSE
CONCERNS TO YOU HERE TODAY. AND
RESPECTFULLY HAD STATE
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
ALRIGHT SAY NOT I WANNA BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE SENATE
WHEN I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING US
FOR THAT THIS COMMITTEE ALSO IS.
USUALLY VERY HIGHLY CRITICAL OF.
LEGISLATION IN THE MIDST OF
LITIGATION BUT I THINK IN THIS
CASE WHAT WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO
DO IS CLARIFY WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE INTENDED IN. IN THIS
AND PROVIDES A BETTER
INSTRUCTIONS TO THE COURTS AS
THEY MOVE FORWARD IN THIS
PROCESS.
AND I THINK THIS BILL IS IT
ABSOLUTELY WORTHY OF OF SUPPORT
AND CASSANDRA I JUST WANT TO SAY
AND I KNOW IT'S DIFFICULT TO
COME AND TESTIFY IN A HEARING
LIKE THIS.
THAT WAS VERY BRAVE AND BUT IT.
I CAN UNDERSCORE ENOUGH HOW
IMPORTANT
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO COME FORWARD
AND TALK ABOUT THE PROCESS AND
WHAT YOU WENT. WENT THROUGH TO
HELP US AS WE WAY.
THE PROS AND CONS OF OF POLICY
AND IN THE END TO UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACT.
THAT THE LAWS WE PASS HAT ON
INDIVIDUALS THAT ESPECIALLY KIDS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR. BEING
WILLING TO COME FORWARD.
AND WHAT ELSE ON THE COMMITTEE.
THE DRESS.
AND THE OPPOSITION I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH YOU. ARE BECAUSE
YOU'RE RIGHT IT WAS.
IF FISCAL.
RESPONSE
TO SOMETHING THAT HAS TO DO WITH
OUR POLICY.
WE WE HAVE NOT DONE ENOUGH TO
PROTECT CHILDREN. WHO ARE
VICTIMS OF CHILDHOOD ABUSE
AND OF THE FACT THAT?
WE'RE GIVING THEM SIX MONTHS.
WE KNOW FROM EVERYTHING THAT'S
BEEN GOING ON WITH THE.
GOING BACK TO THE ME TO
MOVEMENT AND EVERYTHING THAT
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT.
THAT ONE YEAR IS NOT ENOUGH.
IF WE'RE SAYING SIX MONTHS IS
WHAT IS REQUIRED FOR GOVERNMENT
AGENCY WE KNOW ABSOLUTELY THAT
IS NOT ENOUGH.
AND SANDRA.
I TO WANT TO THANK YOU YOU IT IS
AN HONOR TO MEET YOU TO KNOW OF
YOUR SUCCESS.
TO KNOW THAT YOU HAVE BECOME A
VOICE
SO MANY WHO ARE VOICELESS.
YOUR YOUR BEING HERE TODAY IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND
CONGRADULATIONS ADEPT AT CAL
POLY GREAT INSTITUTION.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
BUT I JUST WANNA THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND THINK
YOU CENTER OF COMING AND
SPEAKING I KNOW IT'S DIFFICULT
AND OBVIOUSLY HAVE A BILL THAT
ADDRESSES SOMEWHERE ISSUES.
MOVING FORWARD AT I TRULY
BELIEVE WHAT YOU'RE DOING IT IS
NOT JUST REMEDY IN WHAT WHAT
WENT WRONG IN THE PAST BUT.
PREVENTING WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
FUTURE AND I THINK UNTIL WE HOLD
PUBLIC ENTITIES ACCOUNTABLE THE
SAME WAY WE WOULD A PRIVATE
INSTITUTION THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE.
UNFORTUNATELY TO SEE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND OTHER FOLKS TURN A
BLIND EYE TO TO SOMETHING
BECAUSE IT IT'S IT'S DIFFICULT
TO ADDRESS AND I I DON'T THINK
THAT'S.
HOW WE PROTECT CHILDREN SO?
THANK YOU CENTER BALANCE IF
POSSIBLE I'D LOVE TO BE A CO
AUTHOR ON THIS BILL.
YOU BRING.
OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SCOTT CO AUTHOR THANKS FOR BRING
IT FOR. YOU.
SENATE MIKLOS JUST THE DAWN.
YOU KNOW IF I CAN ADDRESS TO
FISCAL ISSUES I.
I THINK IF ARE A CHILD HAS GONE
A THIRD GRADER HAS SIX MONTHS.
WITH.
THE TIME OF SIX MONTHS TO.
FILE A CLAIM WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
THAT THAT NEVER WAS THE
INTENTION OF THE LEGISLATURE AT
ALL.
AND.
CASES ON SEXUAL ABUSE YOU KNOW
THAT RIGHT THERE'S GOING TO BE.
IS NUMBERED NOT GOING TO BE A
TIME.
WHEN WE HAVE SUPPORT CASE ON THE
ON THE SUBJECT.
SO. I WOULD URGE I WOULD URGE
THAT TOM. WHAT IT COMES TIME IF
THE ARM?
THE FISCAL ISSUES ARE CONSIDERED.
THAT.
THEY ACTUALLY LOOK AT.
FISCAL ISSUES FOR THE CHILD.
AND IMPACT ON THE CHILD IN THE
FUTURE OF THAT CHILD'S LIFE.
AS OF FISCAL IMPACT IF YOU WAT
TO LOOK AT IT THAT WAY.
I THINK WE'LL FIND THAT.
SPILLERS.
A REFLECTION THE LEGISLATORS
PRIORITY AND WOULD SAVE.
.
IF YOU WANT TO LOOK AT IT FROM
US STRICTLY ECONOMIC WAY OF SAVE
THE STATE A LOT OF MONEY.
I DON'T TOOK IT LOOK AT IT THAT
WAY. I LOOK AT THIS IS JUSTICE.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ALL ABOUT
WE PASS THESE LAWS SERGEANT AYE
VOTE HONEST.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THE MOTION IS TO
PASS CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE
BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE CHAU. CHAU AYE
CHIU.
HOLDEN. KALRA.
KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES AYE REYES
AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
AND THEM WE KNOW BOTH ITEM
NUMBER THREE SENATOR HILL S. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN.
MORNING GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR OF AND AND MEMBERS.
S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
WOULD PROTECT VETERANS AND
MILITARY PERSONNEL FROM HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION AND ENSURE THAT
LANDLORDS CANNOT DENY. HOMELESS
VETERANS HOUSING BASED SOLELY ON
THE FACT THAT THEY RECEIVE A
RENTAL ASSISTANCE BALLOT CUT HER.
US VETERANS IN THOSE CURRENTLY
SERVING IN THE ARMED FORCES ARE
PROTECTED FROM EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION BY THE CALIFORNIA
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ACT.
HOWEVER THE LAW DOES NOT
SPECIFICALLY INCLUDE VETERANS OR
MILITARY PERSONNEL AMONG THOSE
WHO ARE PROTECTED FROM HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION.
ALMOST EVERY OTHER PROTECTED
CLASS IN THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING ACT IS PROTECTED IN BOTH
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION STATUTES.
S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
WOULD ADDRESS THIS GAP.
BY ADDING VETERANS AND MILITARY
PERSONNEL AS A PROTECTED CLASS
IN STATUTES RELATING TO HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION.
VETERANS AND MILITARY PERSONNEL
FACE SIGNIFICANT HOUSING
CHALLENGES.
CALIFORNIA HAS A LARGE NUMBER OF
VETERANS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS VETERANS ARE FIFTY
PERCENT MORE LIKELY TO BECOME
HOMELESS THAN OTHER AMERICANS.
A LARGE NUMBER OF DISPLACED AND
AT RISK VETERANS LIVE WITH
LINGERING EFFECTS OF PTSD. AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE WHICH ARE
COMPOUNDED BY A LACK OF FAMILY
AND SOCIAL SUPPORT NETWORKS.
VETERANS ALSO FACE SIGNIFICANT
STIGMA IN THEIR HOUSING SEARCHES.
HAVE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE LANDLORD REPRESENTATIVES IN
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY TO ENSURE
THIS BILL IS APPROPRIATELY
TAILORED.
WITH THE MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS
TO THE BILL THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. AND
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION HAVE AGREED TO
REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION I WANT
TO THANK THEM.
FOR THAT AND FOR THEIR WORK WITH
US IN THIS LEGISLATION.
OUR VETERANS AND MILITARY
PERSONNEL ALREADY FACE
SIGNIFICANT HOUSING CHALLENGES
THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE TO WORRY.
ABOUT BEING DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST WHEN TRYING TO FIND A
HOME FOR THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN WILL
ENSURE OUR HEROES ARE NOT
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST N HOUSING
AND ARE NOT DENIED. HOUSING
BECAUSE OF HOW THEY PAY THEIR
RENT.
AND I WOULD DECISION SUPPORT
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THINK.
THANK YOU FOR THIS IN SUPPORT
PLACE CABINET CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS SET THREE OR THREE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS.
I'M A COMBAT VETERAN WITH TO
COMBAT DEPLOYMENTS OF THE US
ARMY INFANTRY.
.
I'M REPRESENTING AMERICAN LEGION
DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA AMERICAN
GI FORM OF CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY VETERANS.
SERVICE OFFICERS MILITARY
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION. OF AMERICA
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL CHAPTERS
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL VIETNAM
VETERANS ASSOCIATION.
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL.
AND.
OF CALIFORNIA HAS OVER NINE
THOUSAND HOMELESS VETERANS WHICH
IS ABOUT TWENTY FOUR PERCENT OF
THE NATIONAL HOMELESS VETERAN
POPULATION.
AND I CAN TELL YOU WITH PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE NOT THAT I'VE BEEN
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST AND
HOUSING. BUT WHEN INDIVIDUAL
SOME INDIVIDUALS FIND OUT THAT.
SOMEONE LIKE MYSELF WHO AS
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS.
.
THEY LOOK AT YOU DIFFERENTLY.
BECAUSE OF YOUR POSSIBILITY
MENTAL CAPACITY.
.
SO I THOUGHT MY EXPERIENCE JUST
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS FROM BEING
HOME FROM COMBAT.
AND I KNOW THAT THAT HAPPENS AND.
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN'T PROVE.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU FIRST HAND
IT DOES HAPPEN OUT THERE AND I'M
AFRAID THAT IT IS HAPPENING TO
OUR VETERANS THAT ARE COMING
HOME AND.
THEY'RE NOT GETTING A FAIR
CHANCE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STAND
FILLS OUT ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION
.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS.
CREAM THREE CM BATH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS.
HERE TODAY WITH IMPOSING WAS
AMENDED POSITION ON S. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN. OF THE
FIRST COMPONENT OF THE BILL
WHICH SEEKS TO AMEND THE
CALIFORNIA FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING ACT TO INCLUDE BETTER
MILITARY STATUS SEE OURS
PERFECTLY FINE WITH. THAT
HOWEVER THE SECOND HUNDRED
COMPONENT OF THE BILL REDEFINED
SOURCE OF INCOME TO INCLUDE
SECTION EIGHT VOUCHERS FOR
VETERANS AND MILITARY
EFFECTIVELY REQUIRING ALL RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNERS TO PARTICIPATE
IN SECTION EIGHT. UNDER HUD'S
VETERAN AFFAIRS SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING PROGRAM.
IT'S IMPORTANT AT THAT SECTION
EIGHT WAS DESIGNED TO BE
VOLUNTARY BECAUSE UNLIKE CASH
VOUCHERS SECTION EIGHT ENTAILS
EXTENSIVE COORDINATION WITH THE
LOCAL HOUSING AUTHORITY. UNIT
INSPECTIONS AND OTHER
REQUIREMENTS TO TAKE A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF TIME TO
FILL WHILE THE UNITS IT'S VACANT.
MOST NOTABLY SECTION IT REQUIRES
THE LANDLORD TO ENTER INTO A
LEGALLY BINDING CONTRACT KNOWN
AS A HAP WHERE HOUSING
ASSISTANCE PAYMENTS CONTRACT.
S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
WOULD REQUIRE ALL LANDLORDS TO
PARTICIPATE IN SECTION EIGHT
UNDER THE AFOREMENTIONED PROGRAM
BY FORCING THEM TO ENTER INTO A
LEGALLY BINDING CONTRACT THE
PROVISIONS OF WHICH THEY MAY BE
UNABLE TO FILL.
EARLIER THIS YEAR.
SEE OUR WORK WITH THIS
COMMITTEE ON AMENDMENTS TO AB
TWENTY TWO NINETEEN TEN WHICH
ENSURES THAT LANDLORDS CAN
ACCEPT CASH VOUCHERS FROM THIRD
PARTIES WITHOUT ESTABLISHING A
LANDLORD TENANT RELATIONSHIP
WITH THAT THIRD PARTY.
HOWEVER THE BILL EXCLUDED
SECTION A PRECISELY BECAUSE
SECTION EIGHT REQUIRES LANDLORDS
TO CONTRACTUALLY ENTRY INTO AN
AGREEMENT AND SUBJECTS THEM TO
OTHER.
STANDARDS THAT MAY BE
BURDENSOME TO MANY LANDLORDS.
SEE OUR BELIEVES THAT SECTION
EIGHT SHOULD REMAIN VOLUNTARY
AND AS A RESULT OPPOSES US BE
FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN UNTIL THE
MANDATORY SECTION A PROVISIONS
ARE REMOVED FROM THE BILL. AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR NO
VOTE TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THAT'S WHAT.
THANK YOU. GIVING UP MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON RUN KINGSTON
REPRESENT A FOR REGIONAL
APARTMENT ASSOCIATIONS.
CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN CITIES
ORANGE COUNTY EAST BAY AND NORTH
VALLEY PROPERTY OWNERS
ASSOCIATION WE TO.
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO
APOLOGIZE TO.
SENATOR HILL FOR COMING IN LATER
THEN I WOULD HAVE PREFERRED WE
WERE JUST.
IF WE HAD A LOT OF OTHER
PRIORITIES
I'LL HAVE BEEN MEETING WITH
SENATORS STAFF.
THEN HE IT I HAD TO COME BRIEF
CONVERSATION.
TODAY OUR FOCUS IS GOING TO BE
ON A SIMILAR.
OR PARALLEL FACES SAYS THE
REALTORS I AND I WANT TO BRING
THIS HOME IN TERMS OF ITS REAL
PRACTICAL IMPACT.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT BRINGS US TO
ONLY FOCUS IN ON ONE NARROW
PROVISION OF THE BILL. ALL THE
REST OF THE.
PROPOSED CHANGES IN LAW ARE
ACCEPTABLE TO US AND WE ASK.
THAT YOU WERE EMBRACE OUR
REQUEST.
.
THE.
WE ARE NOT FOCUSING ON.
THE VETERANS AT ALL OUR CONCERN
IS THE ACTUAL PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATION.
TALKING WITH SEVERAL OF OUR.
PROPERTY OWNERS WHO HAVE
ACCEPTED VASH NOTABLY AND LOS
ANGELES AND SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
WHO HAVE OF MANY PROPERTIES
HERE ARE EXAMPLES OF WHAT HAS
HAPPENED WHEN THEY HAVE ACCEPTED
OF VASH?
?
HOMELESS VETERAN.
MOST OFTEN WITH EIGHT SO IT'S
ILLUSTRATED BY.
A COUPLE EXAMPLES AND THEN WE'LL
GET TO.
THIS SPECIFICS.
BOB ONE EXAMPLE LANDLORD CHANGES
IT ALL ALL THE CARPETING IN THE
HOUSE.
INSPECTION AND THE.
THE VETERAN MOVES IN.
RECEIVING THE VASH PAYMENT WHICH
AS YOU MAY KNOW IS GOOD FOR A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAYS MAY BE
EXTENDED AND THEN MAY NOT.
IN SIX MONTHS.
AN INSPECTION IS DONE AFTER THE.
HOMELESS VETERAN NOW IS.
I IN THIS RESIDENT.
RESIDENTS.
AND THE INSPECTION NOTES THAT
COULD
SO OIL HERE.
THE CARPETING IS VERY SOILED.
THE INSPECTION.
IMMEDIATELY RESULTS AND.
BARRING THE LANDLORD.
TO.
.
CLEAN THE CARPET AND ABSORB THE
COST.
I AND THEY STOP PAYMENT IN TILL
A MONTHLY RENT UNTIL THAT IS
DONE.
ANOTHER.
SIMILAR.
THERE IS SUCH A PROBLEM WITH.
THE FILTH IN THE UNIT
INSPECTION.
SHOWS THAT AFTER SEVEN MONTHS OF
OCCUPANCY.
GUESS WHAT HAPPENS SAME
REPETITIVE PATTERN ANOTHER.
LANDLORDS WHERE THIS IS
EXPERIENCE AND THEY FIND THAT
WHAT HAPPENS IS.
THE INSPECTION SAYS THERE'S
TREMENDOUS FILL WE ARE
WITHHOLDING RENT CLICK MAKE SURE
IT'S CLEANED UP.
THE BUILDING INSPECTION
DEPARTMENT GETS INVOLVED REFUSES
TO DO ANYTHING DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH.
GETS INVOLVED AND A FEW MONTHS
LATER IT'S FINALLY RESOLVE
LAMBERT HOUSE TO CLEAN THE UNIT
MOVE THE VETERAN OUT OF THE.
UNIT AT THEIR COST.
AND THEN.
THE UNIT IS REKLAME AND IT IS
REPEATED JUST MONTHS LATER THE
SPHINX AND I NEED TO WRAP UP
WITH HER THANK YOU MISTER.
SO HERE IS OUR REQUEST.
.
PROGRAM NEEDS TO BE FIXED.
CASE MANAGERS
FOR EACH OF THE VETERANS
ARE NOT PRESIDENT ONLY JUST
MONTHS AFTERWARDS UNTIL THEY
SHOW UP FORCING THE LANDLORD.
TO.
FIX THE.
OR REPAIR THE PROPERTY AT THEIR
GREAT EXPENSE.
THAT'S ONE OUT OF TWO ISSUES
WERE ASKING THE PROGRAM TO BE
FIXED WHICH MEANS THAT IT.
YEAH I DON'T LAST BUT NOT LEAST.
WE HAVE NOTED IN OUR.
LETTER OF OPPOSITION THAT.
WE FEEL THAT IT IS NOT.
APPROPRIATE FOR US TO BE FORCED
INTO WHAT IS OTHERWISE KNOWN
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES AS
A VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT WHICH IS
FASHION.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
IT'S ENOUGH TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
IF YOU HIS ADDRESS.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE BUT
THE BILL FORWARD.
WE DO HAVE TO DO SOMETHING TO
HELP OUR VETERANS.
SPECIAL HOMELESS VETERANS.
IN READING THE OPPOSITION AND
HEARING THE TESTIMONY A TODAY I
THINK IT IS SOMETHING THAT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED.
AND I DO HOPE THAT YOU WILL
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
FIGURE OUT WAYS TO HAVE THE
INSPECTIONS DONE WHEN OUR
VETERANS MOVIN. SO THAT THAT'S
THE POINT OF EVALUATION THINGS
THAT CAN BE DONE TO HELP SO WE
CONTINUE THE PROGRAM BECAUSE
THAT'S THE IDEA.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE LANDLORDS WHO WILL CONTINUE
TO WELCOME OUR VETERANS I
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT OUR
LANDLORDS TO THEM FOR GET TO A
POINT WHERE THEY SAY WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DO IT AGAIN.
BUT THE THE BILL IS AN
IMPORTANT ONE I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD.
IN THE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SING NONE SANITY MIKLOS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU FOR THE COMMENTS INTO AN AND
I AGREE I THINK THE PROGRAM IN
THE WAY IT'S ADMINISTERED COULD
USE SOME.
HELP AND SOME IMPROVEMENT AROUND
CALIFORNIA'S AND.
IN THOSE HOUSING AUTHORITIES
THAT MAKE SOME OF THOSE
DECISIONS AND CHOICES AND I
THINK. IT'S SOMETHING WE SHOULD
LOOK AT AND I WILL WILL DO THAT.
BUT I DO WANT TO PUT THIS IN IN
CONTEXT THIS YEAR. CALIFORNIA
WAS AWARDED TWENTY TWO HUNDRED.
HIDE BASH ABOUT SHOULD DOCTORS
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED OUT OF SIX
MILLION HOUSING UNITS.
AND THE THE THIS IS A DROP IN
THE BUCKET FOR LANDLORDS AND
THAT'S WHY I APPRECIATE THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
THE.
DROPPING THEIR OPPOSITION THESE
MEN AND WOMEN ARE WILLING TO
MAKE THAT ULTIMATE SACRIFICE IN
AND FOR OUR FREEDOM OF CHOICE AT
LEAST WE CAN DO. IS TO DO THIS
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE PROVIDE. A.
HOUSING VOUCHER FOR IN A FAIR
SHOT AT HOUSING THE OTHER ISSUE.
THAT I THINK IS.
IS INTERESTING IS.
THE CHALLENGES FACED WITH HUD
VOUCHERS AND.
AND THEY HIDE VASH VOUCHERS.
THAT WE HEAR TODAY.
A FEW YEARS AGO WHEN THERE WAS%
NOT A HOUSING SHORTAGE.
THOSE SAME LANDLORDS WERE
STRUGGLING AND BAKING TOGETHER
HIDE SECTION EIGHT VOUCHER.
BUT AS THE MARKET CHANGED THAT
CHANGED AS WELL SO THAT TIME
WILL PROBABLY COME AGAIN. AND
THEY WILL BE UP. HUNGRY FOR
THOSE VOUCHERS WHEN THEN WHEN
THEY NEED IT IS AND WHEN THERE'S
A SHORTAGE SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE MEMBERS AND
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
TODAY.
THANK YOU THEY MOTION WE GIVE A
MOTION A SECOND MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM CHOW. CHOW AYE CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN KALRA. KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN. REYES.
REYES AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE.
THAT NEEDS ONE MORE VOTE THAT
WOULD PUT THAT ON CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FUTURE THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU.
PROGRESS WILL TAKE THAT MOTION
ON ITEM NUMBER FOUR SPR SIXTEEN.
IS THERE SECOND AND WE HAVE A
SECOND THIS THE MOTION IS THAT
THE RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY STONE
AYE CUNNINGHAM. CHAU CHOW AYE
CHU CHU AYE HOLDEN KALRA. KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN.
REYES.
REYES AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE.
THAT IS ALSO ON CALL.
AND NOW WILL TAKE A MOTION ON
THAT PROPOSED CONSENT AGENDA
UNLESS SOMEONE WOULD LIKE TO
REMOVE AN ITEM.
THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. STONE BY
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM CHAU.
SHALL I CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN KALRA.
KILEY.
KILEY I'D MAIENSCHEIN REYES.
REYES AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE.
THOSE ITEMS ARE OUT THAT IS S.
B. THIRTY EIGHT ROTH S. B. SEVEN
SIXTY SIX MONNING S. B. NINE OR
NINE HERTZBERG.
S. B. NINE THIRTY ONE HERTZBERG
SP TEN EIGHTY NINE JACKSON.
S. B. TWELVE A WAIT SENATE
JUDICIARY SP TWELVE EIGHTY NINE
SENATE JUDICIARY SP FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE MORALE. SP FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX PORTANTINO AND SCR
ONE TWENTY EIGHT NO WAY.
RIGHT IF WE COULD GET THE REST
OF MEMBERS HERE LET'S WILL GO
THROUGH THE ITEMS TO ADD ON. AND
IF YOU GET ANY MISSING MEMBERS
HERE WE CAN WRAP UP OUR BUSINESS
TODAY.
SO STARTING WITH. SENSE.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CUNNINGHAM.
CONTENT.
CUNNINGHAM I HOLDEN. KALRA
MAIENSCHEIN.
MENTION I.
THANK YOU AND I NEGLECTED NOTE
BUT ITEM NUMBER ONE S. B. TEN
TWELVE BY HERTZBERG WAS PULLED
FROM THE AGENDA TODAY. SO ITEM
NUMBER TWO BLITZ WAS
HAD ENOUGH VOTES TO PASS BUT WE
WILL ADD ABSENT MEMBERS CALLED
THE UPS MEMBERS PLEASE. CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
THOSE TEN FIFTY THREE ITEM
NUMBER TWO.
WE ENJOY THAT ALREADY
SO ITEM NUMBER THREE IS ON CALL
THAT'S.
I'M GONNA LIFT THE CALL ON S. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN HELLO CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS CUNNINGHAM.
HOLDEN.
KALRA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
THE BILL IS STILL ECONOMY
REPLACE THE CALL ITEM NUMBER
FOUR IS SJ SIXTEEN.
THE BILLS ARE CALM IT WITH THE
CALL.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM AYE HOLDEN
KALRA.
KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I.
THAT RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED BY
THE COMMITTEE IT IS OUT.
SOME HOLD ROLE OPEN FOR A FEW
MORE MINUTES
RIGHT SO LET'S RUN THROUGH THE
GETS INTO ONE MORE TIME CONSENT
AGENDA.
HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE.
I'M NUMBER ONE WAS PULLED FROM
THE AGENDA I'VE EVER TO IS S. B.
TEN FIFTY THREE BELL CALLED
ABSENT MEMBERS HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE.
ITEM NUMBER THREE IS ON CALL
THAT IS S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN HELLUVA LIFT THE CALL.
HOLDEN KALRA. COLOR I.
THAT BILL IS OUT AND ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SJR SIXTEEN BECAUSE THE UP
MEMBERS HOLDEN KALRA.
CALLER I.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH AND WITH
THAT WE ARE ADJOURNED